somos hoje aqui acho que 450 mas
milhares que estão assistindo pela
internet na sexta-feira 343 vocês
aqueles para os quais a organização
tinha o telefone deve ter recebido um
sms com a seguinte pergunta o quão
infeliz você sentiria se r$10
desaparecesse na sua carteira mais ou
menos metade vocês respondeu eu imaginei
que a outra metade tenha ficado
preocupada que se dissesse que não se
importava muito alguém chega aqui de crm
dbm passe 10 reais
mas o mais interessante é a outra
pergunta que vinha para aqueles que
responderam que era a seguinte o que
mais motivou a sua resposta para essa
pergunta foi a sensação de perder alguma
coisa de tiago retirar de você ou foi a
sensação de que você teria que deixar de
comprar agora que você tem 10 reais a
menos na carteira
então a resposta e os resultados da
pesquisa mas pra vocês daqui a pouco por
enquanto eu queria convidar vocês é uma
reflexão mais profunda sobre a segunda
questão
raramente a gente pensa o que a gente
teria que deixar de fazer esses dez
reais não tivessem lá então claro que
pra todo mundo pra quase todo mundo
dinheiro é escasso é mas é como se a
gente estivesse infinitas nota de dez
reais na carteira que nunca é difícil
conseguir pensar como se cada nota de
dez reais fosse a última embora algumas
pessoas gostam de tentar agora isso
acontece até o dia que a gente esquece a
carteira em casa só tem uma nota de dez
reais no bolso e ninguém pra pedir
emprestado nem para vender fiado
nesse dia o mundo inteiro parece ter uma
perspectiva diferente
nossos olhos são atraídos por aquela
prateleira com os produtos mais baratos
que a gente nem prestar atenção e agora
os preços nas etiquetas eles saltam aos
olhos né
nesse dia parece que o momento é
diferente mas obviamente o mundo mudou
o que mudou foi a sua psicologia o que
os psicólogos chamam de banda mental a
sua atenção memória controle da
impulsividade uma maior parte dessa
banda agora está dedicada para prestar
atenção ali nas etiquetas com os preços
você pensar melhor sobre isso vamos
fazer um exercício aqui de quando como
se você tivesse arrumando a mala nem
preparação
a viagem então se chamava é muito grande
muito maior do que o básico que você
precisa para levar essa viagem então
você joga tudo lá de qualquer jeito e
até aquela prancha de bodyboard
encostado na parede cena faz muitos anos
talvez ele seja uma boa idéia é levar
talvez passar só talvez seu uso
agora se você está se preparando da
mesma viagem com a marca uma mala
pequena pequena o suficiente até para o
básico então quando você olha para
aquela prancha um raciocínio
completamente diferente engatilhado pelo
seu cérebro se você levar aquela prancha
o que é que você vai ter que deixar de
levar esse raciocínio esse tipo de
pensamento é que os psicólogos
cognitivos chama de túnel
o túnel da escassez então isso significa
que dentro do que cair dentro do túnel
aquela dimensão que a gente está
enfrentando escassez vai receber uma
maior parte da sua banda mental mas
atenção memória controle da
impulsividade
não é surpreendente então que a gente
fique melhor e mais capaz em tudo aquilo
que cai dentro do túnel
não digo que é pobre por exemplo na
série o supermercado em pesquisas que
mostram que o pobre sabe muito melhor
o preço da pasta desde que ele acabou de
comprar um supermercado do que um rico
porque cada real a mais gastos significa
que ele teria que deixar de comprar
isso não se restringe somente à renda e
se aplica a várias dimensões da vida
então eu digo que ele é muito ocupado
ele enfrenta uma escassez de tempo ele
tem de saber melhor
a duração de cada compromisso no seu dia
isso cai dentro do mtur cada minuto a
mais cara compromisso a mais que
incorpora na agenda significa um
compromisso que vai ter que ser deixado
para amanhã é o turno da escassez de
tempo o indivíduo está fazendo dieta
eficaz e de calorias
ele tem de saber melhor esse caçá é o
teor calórico de cada item o seu consumo
diário
porque para cada caloria mais consumida
significa algo que vai ter que ser
deixado de consumir de ser consumido na
próxima refeição é o dono da escassez de
calorias e se estende até dimensões bem
surpreendentes então indivíduos
solitários são aqueles que têm escassez
de relações sociais
em experimentos de laboratório se você
que eles são significativamente melhores
em reconhecer expressões faciais humanas
nenhum teste de laboratório
talvez porque qualquer expressão mal
interpretada pudesse acentuar essa
condição disse
social então a idéia é claro e super
interessante mas se for só isso sobre o
túnel não teria atraído a atenção como
pesquisador
o interessante é a nossa banda mental é
limitada então mais banda alocada para
aquilo cai dentro do mtur significa
menos atenção memória controle possível
impossibilidade para tudo aquilo que cai
fora do turno
significa então que aquele indivíduo que
é rico o que é que tem escassez de tempo
então ainda que ele saiba melhor com a
duração de cada compromisso no seu dia
significa que ele vai ter menos o
controle da impulsividade para conseguir
evitar que um novo compromisso entre na
sua agenda sem folga para acomodar
pequeno deslize essas essa decisão acaba
sendo crítica
o indivíduo que ele enfrenta escassez de
calorias que está fazendo dieta é que
ele saiba melhor o teor calórico dos
alimentos vai ter menos controle da
impulsividade para conseguir evitar
consumir calorias a mais - polga para
acomodar esse deslize isso vai acentuar
sua condição de escassez significa que o
indivíduo mais pobre
ainda que ele sabe melhor o preço das
coisas que ele compra que ele vai
terminar a atenção memória controle da
impulsividade pra cometer pequenos
deslizes esses deslizes em folga para
acomodar vão acentuar sua condição de
pobreza
o mecanismo que é especialmente de
mandante dessa mandamental empréstimos
vão pensar sobre isso empréstimo
significa mais dinheiro hoje menos
dinheiro amanhã mas hoje para quem
precisa com urgência cai dentro do túnel
de escassez não recebe toda a nossa
atenção nossa consideração enquanto
amanhã tá longe distante acaba recebendo
menos páginas a banda mental dos
empréstimos acabam sendo um mecanismo
muito atraente para quem está numa
situação de escassez mas vão acabar
acentuando essa condição de pobreza
isso como eu estava dizendo não se
refere somente à escassez de renda então
experientes laboratório que é possível
fazer as pessoas artificialmente pobres
de tempo ou ricas de tempo então pensar
num jogo que vocês conhecem angry birds
pelo mundo conhece não tem experiência
que fazem as pessoas algumas pessoas têm
muito tempo para fazer uma pergunta cada
jogada tão rico de tempo não é igual à
de outros são pobres e têm pouco tempo
para fazer cada jogada
então os indivíduos pobres eles levam
menos tempo em que era jogador ele sabe
melhor
o valor de cada segunda mas claro eles
têm uma menor porcentagem de acerto
totais
nesse jogo você permitir preciso tomar
em tempo emprestado a jogar às futuras
para jogar os presentes os pobres de
tempo imediatamente fazem grandes
empréstimos
o tempo para jogar de hoje cai dentro do
turno mas no final de todas as jogadas
eles acabam com uma porcentagem de
acertos ainda menor do que antes que
esses empréstimos tivessem disponíveis
isso reflete aí as consequências dessa
psicologia de escassez nas ciências
sociais têm uma grande divisão um debate
entre aqueles que acreditam que as
pessoas são pobres e funciona suas
próprias decisões
a pobreza culpa do homem aqueles que
dizem que as pessoas são pobres por
causa do ambiente que impõe restrições
que torna essas pessoas pobres é o
cantor discutindo até agora essa nova
pesquisa psicologia mostra que se eu
talvez um falso dilema as duas coisas
interagem o rico não é diferente do pólo
a psicologia a mesma acontece que o
ambiente impõe restrições que
desencadeia a psicologia da escassez itu
não proposta que acaba perpetuando essa
condição em particular diz podia que
inverter essas fotos ea gente vai se
falando não de renda mas de tempo
em geral a pessoa que é mais pobre de
tempo do que o pobre e os erros que o
rio vai comer por causa da situação de
escassez bom acaba perpetuando essa
condição de ocupado
mas talvez nem tem uma condição
permanente ocupado não seja tão crítico
não tem uma perna a condição permanente
de pobreza
então todas essas questões
superinteressante acabou me levando a
questionar se talvez a preocupação com a
seca para o plantio no nordeste do
brasil em particular no ceará
talvez não pudessem ter as mesmas
conseqüências brutais e pra perpetuar as
condições de pobreza desses produtores
se você está preocupado com a água
talvez aconteça no futuro de escassez
também aconteceu dessa forma e levasse a
decisões erradas que perpetuasse a
pobreza desses produtores para começar a
pensar sobre isso eu já digo é como é
que a gente fez isso para falar com
esses produtores mas a gente perguntou
pra eles
duas perguntas o primeiro ou infelizes
eles se sentiriam se eles tivessem dois
litros de água - e para aqueles que
responderam a gente perguntou o que mais
motivou essa resposta anterior foi a
sensação de perder alguma coisa ou a
sensação de que ele teria que deixar de
fazer agora que eles têm dois litros a
menos de água parece familiar né
vocês respondeu posso mostrar primeira
resposta de vocês
então aqui primeiro 19 com infeliz aí
vocês responderam que ficaram se
perdessem 10 reais da carteira mais ou
menos bem distribuído quem respondeu 0
aqui depois da palestra a anj bate papo
mas o que eu queria focar mesmo é na
seguinte pergunta então qual a
porcentagem que respondeu que a primeira
pergunta pensando sempre me dá a
sensação de perder alguma coisa
versos aqueles que pensaram que terão de
deixar de comprar agora tem 10 reais a
menos 65 por cento respondeu que era
simplesmente a sensação de perder alguma
coisa pra mim é muito surpreendente
quando a gente pergunta por outro lado
para os produtores do ceará aí dos
municípios mais secos é daqui o ceará
90% praticamente o território na região
semiárida
a gente faz a mesma pergunta pra ele não
se dá para ver bem aqui mas 70% deles
diz que eles responderam a perguntas
sobre perder água pensando que eles
terão que deixar de fazer se tivesse 2
litros a menos diário então isso mostra
que nesse caso não é de vocês nesse caso
o trio de escassez parecia em
funcionamento
isso não é surpreendente para quem
conhece o estado gostava que a estação
chuvosa que basicamente quatro meses de
fevereiro a maio como prestação curta no
cariri uma prestação só nos anos bons
está bem que o agricultor tem água para
plantar soja durante quatro meses do ano
então é impressionante essa foto aqui
num dos em santa quitéria num dos pontos
mais secos do estado com logo mais o dia
de são josé padroeiro do estado de 19 de
março os agricultores acreditam que se
chover nesse dia então estação chuvosa
vai ser boa
essa crença infundada como tantas outras
ela repete é com crucial a preocupação
com a chuva junto a essa população
tudo isso mostra que talvez título de
escassez tivessem em funcionamento mas a
gente estava documentar se de fato isso
levava a pior atenção memória conta da
possibilidade e decisões que talvez
perpetuasse a condição de pobreza dos
produtores um grande desafio aqui é como
chegar a esses produtores como falar com
eles porque eles estão dispersos por
todo estado é um público muito simples
um público muito carente de acesso a
serviços recurso extremamente limitado
mas que têm uma coisa em comum entre
eles e com a maior parte da população
pobre no brasil
eles possuem telefone celular então 90%
dos domicílios no brasil
possui telefone celular e ainda que 75%
já dos aparelhos vendidos no último
trimestre seja smartphones 80%
basicamente nas ruas continuam sendo
pré-paga brasil tem um telefone mais
cara do mundo um plano de dados mais
baratos que tem custa 25 centavos por
dia que dá 7 50 por mês
parece pouco mas para a gente mas é
muito bom a gente considera que a maior
parte dos celulares no brasil quem chama
de pai de santo é só recebe então era
preciso chegar nele com registro
analógico ele que todo mundo tem celular
mais precisas e sms voz
foi pensando nisso que em 2012 junto com
marcos e rafael pm brasil é uma
consultora em gestão de políticas
públicas e ações de impacto social que o
celular como um canal de comunicação
então a gente coleta dados por exemplo
sobre a porcentagem agricultores que
comprou o programa de seguro do governo
federal e de outro a gente envia
informações sobre a previsão oficial de
chuvas no município o preço dos produtos
que eles mesmo para um exemplo que a
gente faz em março daqui nos municípios
da pesquisa a gente perguntou qual o
porto entre os domicílios que estão
respondendo a pesquisa com a proporção
deles que teve que pular uma refeição na
semana anterior à pesquisa
quanto mais verde que melhora a situação
quanto mais vermelhas você vai ficando
mais crítico isso em março
em junho a mesma pergunta dá pra
perceber aqui que o mapa vai ficar bem
mais alaranjado conformei entre a
estação seca isso conhecido com as áreas
de perda de safra em campo mostrando a
jurado então isso mostra um pouco do
potencial da ferramenta de conseguir
agregar informação dispersa mas que é
importantíssimo para conseguir dar
resposta de políticas públicas imediato
e conseguiu responder com agilidade
nesses dados os produtores vêm fechando
esse parênteses
vamos voltar aqui pra questão disse a
seca afeta ou não usando esse mecanismo
do telefone pensar se a seca afeta ou
não a capacidade cognitiva dos
produtores a gente desenvolveu um teste
simples de memória tem seu encontro de
impossibilidade para fazer pelo telefone
celular por exemplo a gente dizer um
número que não chamada automática de voz
em 52 9 17 e pedir para em seguida o
respondente digitar no telefone número
que ouviu quanto mais disso ele lembrava
melhor a memória de atenção a gente
dizia um número repetir várias vezes
quatro 4444
quantas vezes eu vi o número 4 dá muita
vontade de apertar 4
a resposta não é essa então esses testes
a gente fez pelo telefone pra
identificar a palavra água no meio de
uma sequência de palavras distorcidas se
ouve a palavra água perto um sinal
aberto a 0
as taxas muito simples para conseguir
entender se a seca tinha efeito nem
capacidade cognitiva
agora tem um desafio muito grande quando
a gente vai fazer isso que a gente
simplesmente comparar as respostas dos
agricultores dos municípios mais secos
com a queda dos agricultores nos menus
secos a gente vai tentar capturar o
efeito da seca
ou será que o efeito de tantas outras
coisas que são diferentes entre os
municípios à pobreza acesso ao serviço
da educação coisa diferente então para
realmente conseguiu isolar o efeito da
seca e de outras coisas a gente precisa
fazer como se fosse um laboratório é
simular a psicologia da escassez
a maneira que ele encontrou de fazer
isso foi simplesmente enviar por sms
para 50% dos produtores e também sorteou
50 por cento em março a gente divulgou
previsão oficial da funceme de chuvas
então para uma parte dizer que
precisaria ser normal naquela região que
fossem primeira hora pra outra região
onde dizia que ela é abaixo do normal
para metade os produtores outra metade
recebeu uma mensagem de outra
comparando aqueles que receberam a
mensagem falando que a estação seria
seca para aqueles que receberam uma
mensagem neutra naquela mesma região a
gente achou que aqueles que estavam mais
preocupados com a seca tinham realmente
piora a tensão pior memória pelo
conteúdo e possibilidade mas eram
melhores encontrar a palavra água no
meio daquelas palavras distorcidas e
isso é exatamente o que aquela
psicologia da escassez do túnel
diria que iria acontecer mas a pergunta
talvez mais interessante e se isso de
fato e se refletindo decisões piores que
pudessem perpetuar sua condição de
escassez para testar isso a gente enviou
agora em junho os preços do milho e de
feijão que são duas culturas que todo
produtor praticamente planta aqui no
sertão no ceará e depois mais uma vez né
simulando a psicologia de escassez a
gente testou se aqueles mais preocupados
com a seca lembravam melhor ou pior do
preço dos produtos que a gente enviou e
de fato os produtores mais preocupado
com as equipes lembravam muito menos do
preço que a gente tinha acabado de
enviar por sms
mas o que seria uma tendência acha que o
preço é alto demais
esse mesmo mecanismo em tal acontece na
hora que eles estão aprendendo sobre que
preços vão ter a li3
na frente você vai ser chuvoso não olha
que estão decidindo quanto plantar a
gente estima que isso pode estar
associado a perdas enormes além de até
50 por cento do potencial de renda com
uma determina da saga
só esse mecanismo psicológico é uma
coisa realmente crítica
a grande pergunta e agora porque segundo
o estudo e literatura psicologia é
impossível de mudar faz parte do ser
humano então é uma questão simplesmente
muda queria mudar a psicologia ea
literatura mostra de outro lado que é
possível adaptar ao ambiente essa
psicologia
então quem é pobre quem tem escassez de
tempo ainda que não consiga controlar
esse turno da escassez ele pode
contratar uma secretária secretaria
organiza agenda dele impedindo que os
compromissos se estendem se ainda mais
do que devia ou incluir novos
compromissos na agenda estão vivendo
escassez de calorias pode contratar uma
nutricionista e fazer coisas desse tipo
agora escassez de recursos é muito
particular seja quando não dá pra contar
com o indivíduo para investir modificar
o ambiente a psicologia de outro lado se
uma oportunidade oportunidade para
políticas públicas porque política de
baixíssimo custo por exemplo enviar por
sms o lembrete para se inscrever no
programa de seguro do governo federal
a previsão oficial de chuva do seu
município o preço dos produtos que lhes
vêm depois ter efeitos substanciais em
adaptar esse ambiente essa psicologia
para um público que é muito carente e
está muito preocupada com os efeitos da
seca
a gente enxerga isso como uma
oportunidade aqui ainda para reforçar o
potencial da ferramenta do celular com
né pra chegar todo mundo e se aquietam
os municípios 631 municípios em que a
gente tá fazendo uma pesquisa sobre os
impactos de uma série disse no programa
de primeira infância para crianças de 4
a 6 anos antes desse programa ele era
avaliado só em cinco grandes capitais
agora a gente tá valendo pelo celular em
6 mais de 600 cidades então isso
realmente significa dar voz ao público
para que o público possa expressar sua
demanda por bens e serviços públicos a
sua avaliação de serviço existentes anos
um público não tinha nenhuma maneira de
fazer isso agora pode fazer sem
intermediários
a gente diz que a gente vive hoje numa
era considera do terabyte
a gente pode escolher tudo antes do
tempo inteiro está fazendo escolhas
agora nossa democracia é como se a gente
tivesse não era do bits a cada quatro
anos a gente é convidado a contribuir
com uma decisão binária você que esse
cara aqui
outro então o que a gente espera que com
essa ferramenta a gente possa conter um
pouquinho para também levar nossa
democracia a era do trabalho obriga